vamos a ver si podemos averiguar cuánto
es tres cuartos menos cinco octavos para
empezar tenemos representados de manera
gráfica justo aquí estos tres cuartos
podemos ver esta barra entera como un
entero y puedes ver que está dividida en
cuatro secciones iguales y sólo tres de
ellas están iluminadas entonces estas
tres partes de color de verde
representan tres cuartos de un entero y
lo puedes ver justo aquí esto es tres
cuartos ahora bien esta otra parte que
tenemos aquí abajo lo puedes ver como
otro entero que está dividido en ocho
partes iguales y sólo cinco de ellas
están iluminadas de color morado estas
representan cinco octavos de un entero
son estas cinco partes de color morado y
lo puedes ver aquí estos cinco octavos
están representados por esta parte que
tenemos aquí
entonces está de lujo entonces esta vez
tenemos tres cuartos esta parte de verde
ya esto le queremos quitar cinco octavos
la parte de morado así que cómo podemos
hacerlo y bueno espero que al verlo
puedas entender mejor y te bring el
resultado ahora bien recuerda que cuando
sumamos ahora estamos fracciones nos
gusta trabajarlo en términos de un mismo
denominador para así trabajar todo en
cuartos u octavos y dieciseisavos o lo
que tú quieras
así que busquemos un denominador común y
un buen denominador común para estas
fracciones será un múltiplo común entre
los denominadores que tenemos aquí y
queremos encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo y una forma para encontrarlo
ojo hay muchas formas para encontrarlo
pero una forma es ver al número mayor
entre estos dos denominadores y en este
caso es el
y vamos a buscar entre los múltiplos de
81 que también sea divisible por 4
perfectamente divisible por 4 pero de
inmediato vas a decir que bueno 8 es
divisible por 4 y claramente es
divisible por sí mismo así que 8 de
hecho es nuestro mínimo común múltiplo
el mínimo común múltiplo entre 8 y 4 así
que podemos reescribir ambas fracciones
en términos de octavos
es decir cuyo denominador sea 8 entonces
tres cuartos nos va a quedar como algo
algo entre 8 ya veremos que va acá
arriba ya esto le vamos a restar bueno
le vamos a restar 5 octavos porque esta
fracción ya tiene como denominador el
así que a esto le vamos a quitar cinco
octavos y esto es lo que buscamos de
respuesta y bueno como vamos a poder
escribir tres cuartos en términos de
algo entre ocho bueno pues hay un par de
formas de hacerlo una de ellas es pensar
mira primero tengo un 4 como denominador
y después tengo el doble de 4 como
denominador tengo el doble de secciones
iguales que las que tenía antes así que
multiplique por 2 estás de acuerdo y
entonces para tener el numerador habrá
que multiplicarlo por la misma cantidad
porque queremos tener el doble de
secciones iguales por lo tanto también
habrá que multiplicado por 2 y 3 por 2
es lo mismo que 6 entonces tres cuartos
es lo mismo que seis octavos y lo
podemos observar justo aquí si vamos a
dividir algo que ya estaba dividido en
cuartos y ahora vamos a dividir todo en
dos secciones iguales entonces al
dividir cada
en dos secciones iguales voy a obtener
octavos así que hagámoslo vamos a
dividir lo voy a dividir esta primera
parte y me va a quedar más o menos así a
la mitad voy a dividir esta parte y me
va a quedar más o menos así a la mitad
voy a dividir esta parte y me va a
quedar más o menos así a la mitad y voy
a dividir esta parte y me va a quedar
más o menos así a la mitad y ahora
observa que estoy pasando de cuartos a
octavos y entonces ahora voy a terminar
con cuántas partes iguales
bueno pues observa voy a tener 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 partes iguales y podemos ver que
seis de ellas están de color verde
entonces tres cuartos es lo mismo que
seis octavos uno dos tres cuatro cinco o
seis y con esto ya podemos restar las
tenemos seis octavos menos cinco octavos
así que si empezamos con seis octavos
que es esta parte de aquí y queremos
quitarle cinco de ellos
vamos a hacerlo quitamos uno quitamos
dos tres cuatro cinco de ellos los
cuales corresponden a los cinco octavos
que teníamos acá abajo ahora si observas
los verdes
empezamos con seis octavos y le quitamos
cinco octavos
entonces le quitamos uno de ellos le
quitamos otro de ellos otro de ellos
otro más y otro más quitamos cinco
octavos y qué nos queda bueno pues
simplemente me voy a quedar con este
octavo que tengo aquí y entonces mi
respuesta va a ser 1
y también lo podemos ver aquí de una
manera numérica si tengo seis de algo en
este caso octavos y le restó 5 de ese
mismo álbum en este caso cinco octavos
entonces me quedo con uno de eso mismo
en este caso un octavo